A new year is upon us! Are you ready to
make it your best language learning year,
ever? I certainly am, thanks to my simple
6-step yearly plan. If you want to learn
how to crush it in 2023 and take all your
language goals to the next level, stay
tuned—because I'm going to show you how right now. Hey, I am Luca Lampariello, I am a language coach
who speaks 14 languages. and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages more
efficiently, faster and in a fun way.
So, do you want to know how to crush
your 2023 language goals? Let’s dive right in!
To make the most of the new year, you need to
do two very important things:
Reflect on your progress
over the PREVIOUS 365 days
Plan your learning for the NEXT 365 days.
This is very different from how people
traditionally go about setting their
goals at this point of the year. Typically,
people just set their New Year's Resolutions
around what they'd like to accomplish at
the end of the year, and just go for it.
THIS plan requires a little more thinking,
but it does a better job of setting you up for
success. It encourages you to build upon your
last year of learning experiences by creating
an action plan at the three-month, one month,
and daily levels. As a result, you'll always
be aware of what you should be working on,
and you'll always be able to stay on track.
But enough theory! Let's talk
about the steps of this plan,
so you can put it into practice and CRUSH 2023! The six steps of the plan are as follows:
Reflect on your language learning
progress over the past year
Assess your current language skills
Visualize yourself one year from now
Establish key goals and objectives
for the next three months
Break down your key goals into daily habits.
Review (and adjust) your plan every three months
Step 1: Reflect on your language
learning progress over the past year
The first thing you must do is look back on
the previous year, and think about all that
you've accomplished in your language learning.
Here, it's useful to ask yourself a number
of guiding questions, including:
What went well in the past year?
What didn't go so well?
In which areas did I improve the most?
In which areas do I still need to improve?
What were my biggest lessons
learned over the year?
You don't need to be too rigid
with exactly how you go about this. The goal is simply to get a general idea of your recent "wins"
and "losses" so you can use this information tocreate a more optimized plan for the coming year.
For example, here's what I wrote when
reflecting on my Hungarian learning for 2022:
I managed to learn Hungarian very regularly
throughout 2022, spending some time with the
language at least 4-5 days each week. Also, I
modified my practice activities to be mainly
input-based, as opposed to the output-based
activities I’d been doing previously. I
mainly prioritized listening to podcasts
and watching YouTube videos, though I did
read the occasional book, as well. My favorite
podcast resource has been Hungarian with Sziszi.
2022 was also a great year for my Hungarian
learning because I had the chance to visit
Budapest and spend an entire month there duringthe summer. I’ve been to Budapest before,
but this was the first time that I really felt
comfortable using the language in everyday
life. I also had a much easier time speaking
with natives than I’ve had in previous years,
and at one point, I even managed to have a
two-hour conversation with my tutor, Petra!
In terms of takeaways, I can think of three:
Learning (almost) everyday really pays off
Solid input skills are essential in
order to build solid output skills
Traveling to the country where a language is
spoken can be a great reward for hard work,
as well as a worthy challengethat can spur future growth.
You see? Creating a short-but-sweet synopsis ofthe previous year's efforts can help you gain
a clear perspective on what you have to do next. Speakng of "what you have to do next", let's move
on to the second part of our planning process.
Step 2: Assess your current language skills
When you're learning a language, what you're
actually doing is developing a network of
interconnected skills in your brain. The four
most prominent of these skills are listening,
speaking, reading, and writing.
To determine which of the four
skills you want to develop in the coming year, youshould first take stock of your current abilities,
so you can get a good idea of your
strengths and weaknesses as a learner.
This is easier than it sounds. All you
have to do for this step is think of a
few things you're capable of doing in each of
the major skill areas. It may also be useful to
highlight what you currently cannot do in these
areas, so that you know what to work on next.
Here's how I recently evaluated
my skills for Hungarian:
Reading
I can read scripts
of podcasts aimed at B2 learners, and I’ve justbegun reading books aimed at native speakers.
Listening
My ability to understand
podcasts and videos has improved drastically. Inparticular, I’m most comfortable with the podcasts
that both Sziszi and Petra produce, and I’m evenmanaging to understand YouTube videos on certain
complex topics. I can’t understand news broadcastsyet, but my listening ability in general is much
improved over where it was one year ago.
Speaking
I can hold conversations on most everyday topicswithout major problems. I still hesitate and make
mistakes, of course, but overall I feel quite
comfortable, even during longer conversations.
Writing. I didn’t focus on building my writing
skills in 2022, so I can’t really evaluate them
at this point. However, I plan to begin keeping
a daily journal in Hungarian starting in 2024.
Not too bad, right? The point of this step is
to describe your language abilities in concrete
terms, so that there's less guesswork when it
comes to the type of practice you need
to build into your new learning plan.
On to Step 3! Step 3: Visualize yourself one year from now
The last step was all about objectively
evaluating where your language abilities
are. This next step is about emotionally
evaluating where you want your language
abilities to be, one full year from now.
Why bring emotions into a learning plan? Well,
your emotional state strongly influences
how motivated (or unmotivated) you are
to do something. If we can tie strong
positive emotions to your language goals,
then you'll be much more likely to stick
with them, even when the going gets tough.
We can build this connection between our emotionsand our goals through creating a visualization.
More specifically, by visualizing our future
self after he or she has accomplished all the
goals that we are about to set in this plan.
I like to treat this as a kind of meditative
exercise. I close my eyes, and try to create
a vivid mental picture of myself at the end
of the year, doing all the things I want
to be able to do in my target language.
Once I've created a sufficiently vivid mental
image, I write it down, so that I can refer to
it and expand upon it throughout the year.
Here's the end-of-year visualization
I recently created for Hungarian:
31 December, 2023 - I am in Budapest,
drinking a glass of pálinka in my friend’s
apartment. We’re having a party, and I’m speaking
Hungarian with the people there. Everyone I talkto is amazed at how well I speak Hungarian. “Wow,
your pronunciation is incredible!” one person
says. “You’re so fluent!” says another. I’m
excited, because I plan on spending several
months in Budapest in 2024, and I’ll surely
improve even more by then. The future is bright!
This kind of visualization exercise may sound
corny at first, but I can assure you
that the results can be quite powerful,
especially when you keep the written version handyand look at it whenever you're tired, stressed,
or otherwise unmotivated to learn.
Ok, time for Step 4!
Step 4: Establish key goals and
objectives for the next three months
The previous steps should have given you a goodidea of where you need and want to improve your
language skills by the end of the year.
It's time now to take those general ideas
and boil them down to concrete goals—to things youabsolutely want to accomplish in the next 90 days.
Why 90 days? Because that's how we're
going to take the whole year and make
it a bit more digestible. Instead of thinking
about all 365 days at once, we'll primarily
focus on 90 days at a time, which helps us
remain focused in the short and medium-term.
So, ask yourself: based upon your previous
year's learning, your current level,
and your visualization, what do you want to haveaccomplished by the end of the next three months?
Your answer can be anything, so long as it
leads you towards the version of yourself
you just pictured in your visualization.
Here are the language goals that I want
to accomplish by the end of March 2023:
I want to able to understand most podcasts
aimed at learners, especially Sziszi’s
podcasts, even the most difficult ones.
I want to be able to understand YouTube
videos to a good 60-70 % without subtitles,
be it content for Hungarian learners
or for native Hungarian speakers.
I want to be able to understand at least a
good 60-70% of the news without subtitles.
I want to be able to greatly improve my
reading skills, especially when it comes
to reading books, be it non-fiction or novels.
I want to improve my spoken fluency to a level
where I feel comfortable speaking both with myteacher and native Hungarian speakers in general.
Step 5: Break down your
key goals into daily habits
Goals are useful for providing a “finish line”,
but do little to help you manage the day-to-day
work of language learning. You've just created
your three-month goals, but the key now is
to take those goals and identify the daily
actions that will help you reach them. These
daily actions will constitute your “habits”.
Any habit will suffice here, so long as it
consists of something that, if done daily, will
realistically get you to your three-month goal.
In the last section, I mentioned that I want tobe able to listen to a certain level of podcast,
watch a certain level of YouTube video
without difficulty, and even watch the news
comfortably. To do that, I'll naturally have
to spend daily time consuming more podcasts,
videos and news until I reach that level.
Here is a list of a few habits that come directly
from the goals I have established for 2023:
I want to listen to at least one episode of
the Hungarian with Sziszi podcast every day,
and even take her course, once it’s available!
I want to watch at least 3 YouTube videos a week. I want to watch the Hungarian news for
at least five minutes a day.
I want to be read at the very
least 2-3 pages of a book every week.
I want to talk to my Hungarian tutor
Petra at least once a week and
review the lesson 24 hours later
Step 6: Review (and adjust)
your plan every three months
The last step in our six-step planning sequenceis actually a recurring one. Every three months,
you should take out your learning
plan to review and revise it
Additionally, you should revisit Steps 4 and
5, and come up with both goals and habits for
the next three months. Naturally, since the year
can be divided up into four periods of 90 days,
you'll have to come up with four 90-day plans
before the year is done, so keep that in mind.
Since it's only January, and this is something
you'll have to do regularly throughout the year,
I recommend using a calendar or setting up
some kind of recurring reminder for you to
return to your plan every three months
and set up your new goals and habits.
Alright, those are all the steps of my
six-part annual language learning plan.
Sitting down every January to plan
my language learning like this has
done wonders for my ability to stay focused
and make serious progress in recent years,
so I'm certain that it will create
powerful results for you, as well.
Let's quickly recap the six
steps of the planning process:
Reflect on your language learning
progress over the past year
Assess your current language skills
Visualize yourself one year from now
Establish key goals and objectives
for the next three months
Break down your key goals into daily habits
Review (and adjust) your plan every three months
Before we go, I want to leave you with one
final tip: once you write out your yearly plan,
print it out, decorate it, and leave it
somewhere where you'll always see it when
you sit down to learn. This will serve as
a powerful reminder of why you're learning,
and also help you remember to review
and revise the plan as the year goes on.
If you'd like to learn more about
how I plan my language learning,
check the links in the description box,
as I've left some goodies for you there.
In any case, thanks for watching. I wish
you all the best as you begin this new year,
and I sincerely hope you're able to achieve
all of your language goals by year's end.
See you next time! Until
then, happy language learning!